Les experts de kpmg roulaient dans l'argent
qu'ils avaient trouvé de l'or pour cacher
la fortune de certains de leurs
Canadiens les plus riches derrière les forteresses de l'île de Man
dans le plus grand secret la
Sonata da da
Medusa Viscusi Kamala's Angela rivet le
détective mais aujourd'hui les clients révèlent comment
le Sham  fonctionne la
réalité de Salah supposerait que
Lakeisha, l'élection de l'absolution de contrôle de Kinsella
pour la dernière fois du Likud grâce à
KPMG, ces multimillionnaires n'ont jamais eu
à faire face à des poursuites judiciaires, un équilibre que
Davidoff a commencé à avoir s'il s'agit d'une
force de surface de Michaels autour de la
boucle vitae à la place l'Agence du revenu du Canada
leur a offert un  permis d'amnistie dans l'
amnistie gal l'agence a dit qui sont
ces clients mystérieux notre
enquête nous mène à certains des
Canadiens les plus riches protégés par l'un des
cabinets comptables les plus influents
du pays
[Musique]
Madrid l'une des grandes
capitales européennes événements riches et culturels  la
destination touristique idéale pour attirer des
fiscalistes du monde entier  e monde à la conférence de l'
International Fiscal Association l'
un des principaux sponsors de
la conférence est le géant comptable KPMG
à l'ordre du jour cinq jours de réunions
conférences et discussions sur
les questions de fiscalité internationale l'utilisation des
paradis fiscaux par les riches et les
multinationales est devenue très
controversée et les experts  sachez que le
vent tourne alors que les Panama Papers et maintenant
les affaires des Bahamas nous ont montré qu'il
y a un ressentiment croissant contre la
structure fiscale mondiale, en particulier dans le contexte
des impôts
et vous avez juré de vous opposer aux autorités fiscales
pour les riches, les plus grands
cabinets comptables sont prêts pour la première
bataille  des meilleurs associés de KPMG était très
clair dans cette vidéo d'entreprise de 2015 si
nous laissions simplement les régulateurs si nous laissions les autres
parties prenantes découvrir à quoi ressemblera le paysage fiscal,
je ne suis pas
si sûr que ce sera
franchement bon pour nos clients pour  nous, mais de
manière réaliste pour la société, je pense que nous pouvons
aider à construire un système fiscal de l'avenir
et j'ai hâte de  être une grande partie
de cette reconnaissance nationale à Kitab mon
animal de compagnie foxy Dollansky Yacouba CUDA Velma
chanson kappa - Je suppose que cela montre un
fiscaliste international dyslectique
Marwa risqué dit que les grands cabinets comptables
sont au cœur des problèmes d'
évasion fiscale et de chimiorécepteur d'évasion fiscale
SCL
il y a une vingtaine d'années, les grands
cabinets d'experts-comptables se faisaient concurrence pour
créer des stratégies fiscales de
plus en plus rentables mais aussi de
plus en plus risquées. Je pense que l'on avait l'
impression qu'ils ne se faisaient jamais prendre.
nous.  à l'époque, l'
environnement était constitué de transactions qui
étaient vendues qui étaient très risquées et
nous ne représentons pas les faits réels de
la transaction avec une décision commerciale
et si elle était conforme ou non à la
loi que le préjudice d'enfreindre la
loi était essentiellement  une tape sur le poignet
et vous pourriez devenir riche en le faisant
au Canada - les experts fiscaux de KPMG ont
proposé un stratagème offshore très lucratif
selon des documents internes, les
clients ciblés devraient avoir plus de 5 millions de
dollars à investir à l'étranger la chienne était
alléchante pas d'impôt sur le revenu  à payer sur les
gains en capital et la confidentialité garantie pour
chaque vente
KPMG gagnerait au moins 100 000 $ à l'
interne l'entreprise a claironné des
ventes réussies louant dit bolado un
partenaire montréalais un homme d'affaires canadien a accepté de
révéler anonymement le contenu de ses
rencontres confidentielles avec un
partenaire de KPMG sondage G safer Peggy  lamorne
Apple OCC possible Nepal / ug - in Maui
Pandu viene de votre image parlant de
domici  le ton Ansel Valley fait Apache
fiscale mal une petite démo l'île de Man
est située dans la mer d'Irlande le
taux d'imposition des sociétés est de zéro pour cent KPMG en
tant que bureau dans la capitale Douglas KPMG
crée une société offshore pour son
client l'entreprise recrute également à l'île  des
résidents de Man, ce seront des actionnaires nominés,
le client canadien cède sa
fortune à la société offshore qui
s'installe devient la sélection de la ville un
leader maintenant la cage de ceccacci les
aimait de manière attrayante si accrocheuse qu'ils ne l'apaisent
pas venir elle mouille a voyagé de façon folle fait
confirmer que vous avez un  déclaration le client
ne déclare rien à l'
Agence du revenu du Canada puisque techniquement il n'est plus
le propriétaire au fil du temps sa fortune grossit
lorsqu'il veut ramener des fonds
au Canada tout ce qu'il a à faire est de demander à l'
entreprise de lui faire un don un don libre d'impôt
mais selon le professeur de droit Andre
laho c'est de la fumée et des miroirs los que
le configurable Oh homie de la Rosa l'
élasticité della dama de marrón de la
Rosa a coûté une élite a c  at
lair por que pasol kailasam de valor revenue
mr twemlow sin episode Oh chien LoCascio une
agence immobilière donc par défaut Cal personnes et
esprit de Barras amis de la rocca pmj
pauvre pécheur clé de document infinitif
vitani - donc la logique de test de Larson sait
sanneh Oh maudit les fonctionnaires catholiques de Chadwick
plaidoyer Ladera tablette ou
opération sociale même s'il n'est pas
actionnaire le multimillionnaire garde le
contrôle de sa fortune en siégeant au
conseil d'administration csleater pada
Corrigan transaction is Nava transaction
Java ME mo Java et qu'est-ce qui met son veto pour
créer un écran encore plus opaque
KPMG recommandait à ses clients de demander à un
ami de confiance de siéger au conseil d'administration pour
eux. Le plan de kpmg comprenait également un
accord secret qui donnerait au
client de son ami un
pouvoir extraordinaire à tout moment, il pourrait liquider
l'entreprise et ramener l'argent au
Canada
Oh bud  Cort dire à Zula control
absolution aha
choc touristique Bhupati 18 façade todo
militant Oscars lipid control solar
compan  y peut livrer sûrement Tsubasa
Je sélectionne ceux-ci sont acaba
séjour unidirectionnel capitaine travailleur aucune
robe trouvée absurdité ne fais pas le soleil l'
élégance peut correspondre à une clé d'ammoniac de 0,8
exposer les non-fans Calatrava merde vous voyez la
grammaire des propriétaires et comme je suis il a fait
un  bonne action II n'a même pas envoyé d'e-mail à
KPMG qui conteste catégoriquement qu'il s'agit d'une
déclaration fiable indiquant que les clients
ont été explicitement informés qu'ils
abandonnent le contrôle des actifs à ce jour
ni les clients de KPMG ni l'entreprise
elle-même n'ont été accusées d'
évasion fiscale criminelle onhc  pas de ville de pardon donc SCO
nutella's Japon Claire modérée aussi
consommateurs de tonalités je sais voir détente Tosca
suppose ela Castillo qui a dit que certaines
Cassie collectent
namazi bien secret Ola méritent un
café chinois un kanji à l'
unité de dilution vaginale sous notification la
confidentialité à Fallujah peut repousser
dosa Akiko Kamala's  tout encore de la nouvelle
Vitesse détecte un monsieur en effet le fisc canadien
n'a rien détecté
jusqu'en 2012 à Victoria la Coope  r famille
vivait dans des maisons de luxe mais ils ont déclaré
des revenus si faibles qu'ils payaient très
peu ou pas d'impôts du tout ils
réclament même des crédits d'impôt
mais ils se sont assis sur un énorme 26 millions de
dollars les agences de revenu les giflent avec
une pénalité de six millions de dollars
le cas est avant  la Cour canadienne de l'impôt,
je pense que vous devez parler à
KPMG, tout était caché derrière une
structure de société offshore sur l'île
de Man, c'est là que nous avons poursuivi notre
enquête avec le professeur Lihue, nous
avons été accueillis par un mur de silence quelque chose
comme ça, un local commun après un
jugement sur Saravanan DeCoteau reprendre
le partage des revenus en direct la cerveza de nies
agua a déclaré la liste vanille dakea daca
PMG a dr.  Nadeau Lisa Quichotte vivre le
bonheur ici à Vancouver les
enquêteurs de l'Agence du revenu ont obtenu une
ordonnance du tribunal en 2013
KPMG a été chargé de remettre les
noms de ses clients mais il a refusé et a
fait appel de la décision et puis rien pendant
plus de deux ans
l'affaire était grande Kizuna va coûter  nous
Cap'n astana sake pas de mégapole fonctionnelle
KPMG verse quoi que ce soit derrière des portes closes
KPMG concluait un accord avec l'Agence du revenu
afin que ses clients riches ne soient
pas traduits en justice Les clients riches de KPMG
pouvaient toujours profiter de la vie et ne pas
trop s'inquiéter même si le revenu du Canada
L'agence avait jeté son dévolu sur eux,
le puissant cabinet comptable avait
réalisé un exploit remarquable en
négociant pour eux un accord secret que
nous avons obtenu d'une source anonyme, les
clients n'avaient qu'à payer les arriérés d'impôts
à un taux d'intérêt réduit, sans
pénalité ni poursuite
échange l'Agence du revenu a exigé que son
offre reste strictement confidentielle à
moins que la famille ne soit au courant d'autres
aérosols cryptés sca  n à propos de l'impact du moto SC
sur l'effet les massages sont pires
se produisent lelou un caucus septique à Ottawa
nos révélations sont venues comme une bombe
l'OS canadien est une aventure Merci
Pierre Metro mentionne en el deporte a la
sample a dispel Kathy open season on
polygon de  fiscalité de qualité montebello qui
peut vraiment vous identifier arrêtez tout Depot n'est
pas un test ichika brahma le nouveau
premier ministre libéral était prêt à reconsidérer
l'accord conclu sous le
gouvernement conservateur quelles décisions
prises sous un gouvernement précédent si
leurs erreurs les examineront à
coup sûr un mois  plus tard, les libéraux ont augmenté
le budget de l'agence et annoncé de nouvelles
mesures San Jose Mesa plastique émettent une
pièce d'identité consultative pada seule observation
clé électronique soutien consolidation
fiscal Ally transy el aprendizaje
La maladie de Kelly de Sophie sept
experts indépendants conseilleront le ministre
deux d'entre eux du consultant fiscal québécois
Alan Lottie en  professeur de droit fiscal Mary T
Allah Emma conscience après la circoncision
fo me swift
Allah SAS KPMG kaydessa Syrie pour devenir
un chat Jasmine sont les libéraux ont permis
au comité des finances d'étudier l'
offre d'amnistie aux clients de KPMG
finalement l'affaire allait être
mise au jour mais en fait c'est l'
inverse qui s'est produit ce matin
étude de mot de  Les efforts de l'Agence du revenu du Canada
pour lutter contre l'évasion et l'évitement fiscaux ont
été le premier témoin, l'
ancien chef mondial de l'herbe à poux de kpmg, qui
étaient les employés de l'ARC qui ont négocié
l'accord d'amnistie avec KPMG chez votre
client. Je ne suis pas autorisé à parler d'aucun
aspect de la  du règlement parce
qu'il est soumis au privilège du règlement qui
étaient vos principaux contacts avec l'ARC comme je l'ai
dit plus tôt c'est un aspect de
cette conversation que je
ne peux malheureusement pas entrer dans les humains comme sur les contrôles du parti
Pascal : fois préserver un
dilemme ici à Holloman pgb Lucca
viande sur  9 juillet Picabo sauf à
travers protège la confidentialité
Gregg wieb dit que le régime de l'homme d'olive était
tout à fait légal au t  ime comme c'est le
cas avec tous nos plans fiscaux, il
respectait pleinement toutes les lois fiscales applicables, nous avons
mené une
diligence raisonnable interne et externe approfondie en mettant un
investissement et une société offshore et
en revenant ici au Canada en tant que cadeau
d'une société à une autre société
pensez-vous  ce genre de comportement est immoral,
nous avons déterminé en 2003 que c'était
quelque chose que nous n'étions plus
prêts à mettre en œuvre en tant qu'organisation,
c'était une époque très différente
.  savoir dans nos
voitures jusqu'à il y a deux ans, les temps changent
et nous changeons avec lui envoyé des
jeux populaires comme un
cordial transveineux  Coolidge quel était
le revenu total reçu par KPMG pour
ce package particulier offert les 16
implémentations, les frais moyens étaient d'
environ 100 000 $, donc les frais totaux que
nous avons  aurait reçu pour la
mise en œuvre de ce plan particulier était
juste en deçà de la fourchette de 1,6 million de dollars
c'était des frais fixes par mise en œuvre ce
n'était pas des frais conditionnels
mais son témoignage est contredit par un
document de marketing interne déposé au
tribunal le cabinet comptable déclare  que
les frais annuels jusqu'à quinze pour cent des
économies d'impôt pourraient être construits selon
l'agence du revenu les frais payés par Cooper
à KPMG jusqu'en 2008 au total
300 000 $ KPMG dit que ce ne sont que des
allégations de l'agence du revenu les
informations fournies par Gregg weed à la
Chambre  Le comité des Communes avait raison
pour les tours de mois les plus efficaces sur l'
heure de Matsu palomar dans laquelle je peux sauter
ne parlez-vous pas de Christine de la Fidele
et scannez aussi - l'Italie ne me fait pas peur
, profitons-en seulement quelques semaines
après KPMG  témoignage
c'est au tour des ministres du revenu de
répondre et de répondre aux questions sur l'
amnistie secrète de votre puissant à Novato
dans les
pécheurs de densité yazhini seuls le p  clé de resento
spécifiquement jacques de classe de
Clairvaux délivre émission ESMA non gras
réveillé pénalité attribuée bavière tasaku
tonalité illest OG o intolérance et -
honnêteté Masuka comment vida nationalité
musica courbe de taille où est Vicki Layton
et mamelon mystère n MK e gdz dans ce
rapport est une séquence spéciale  détective
McCormack L amnistie administrative
shakaal une telle affaire de diffamation sur della
patria
deuxième annonce la majorité du laboratoire Papa ye dis une
minute le ministre a même refusé de
confirmer l'authenticité de la lettre
offrant l'amnistie aux clients de KPMG
activer l'alerte du château pour laver plus tard le
transit dans  Peut-être même pour voir le
document des communautés permet Evelyn laissez-
moi supposer qu'un homme existe un fabricant de bombes nouvelle
taille Solanki désirs clairs
ne faisons pas oh c'est nee avec vine site
clear sis cuticle nipper Palakkad le
résidu kannada adah cbc s-curve with a
super confirmer sortie externe coupe le
coût total soutien supplémentaire immédiat
malicieusement Presutti l a déclaré crimina  l
à palana pas d'oscillation SoLoMo notre
signal physiquement dynastie de quelques
étudiants, elle peut dépasser le genou énorme,
ne laissons pas le comité appeler ensuite une
série d'experts indépendants, mais le
jour de l'audience, ils ne peuvent pas entrer dans la
salle le  comité se réunit à Camera
Raw mille une dernière poupée kalila consulter
dr.  Hayden McHale systole appelle la
réunion à deux ordres tout d'un coup le
président du comité libéral wainy
serf ordonne aux experts de ne pas parler
du scandale KPMG Daz je crois qu'un témoin
ou un membre se dirige dans une direction
qui pourrait avoir des implications sur le
tribunal  cas alors je leur demanderai d'
être coupé et et passer à la question suivante
pochamma abeja combi apt ASP Sofia
SEO direct compliqué van der kappa OMG
le de pas égal au coup l'
inepte préservé sa innocent de
répliques panzanella mr.  LaRue
bonjour dans votre chambre oh non pas vraiment
qui est le professeur diversité calles de
Laval
Giovanni celada a lil Dena por la que de
la Li da y ji Liberty Molotov ASEAN se
Swasey
de ribera de la cienega aucun doc n'apparaît une
torsion malignité commune pop un leader
kappa OMG le de ma robuste métabee
ennoblissement la stratégie moi topless
daca PNG en haut sur le podium pop je
préférerais que tu n'entres vraiment pas dans
le KP
l'affaire c'est celle qui est juste
devant les tribunaux si tu veux parler dedans
généralités sur l'évasion fiscale c'est
bien mais je ne veux pas emprunter un chemin
ce n'est pas un Castro mr.  président que nous
venons juste d'être invité à parler du service de
livraison d'opportunités énergétiques KPMG Kappa
Oh la Commission de la défense est toujours des
émissions de télévision comme une analyse des coûts
déceptions périodiques Casio vascularité SEMA médecin
au comité Hollander pourquoi le
président du comité a-t-il fait
un couple à l'envers  Quelques jours plus tôt, les avocats de KPMG ont
envoyé une lettre au comité invoquant
la règle du sous-Gudice, une règle qui dit
qu'il ne faut pas interférer dans le
processus judiciaire,
mais Wayne Easter dit que la lettre n'a eu aucune
influence sur lui, les conseils que nous avons
examinés provenaient du juriste parlementaire
conseil et jusqu'où vous devriez ou
ne devriez pas aller si freaking la voce Lang
handicap por semana de Anita's expand
isatis AMA La Palma pooh-pooh silica
certains enfants étaient conv Kelly T singe a
déposé du silicium uniquement Trevino silica
sunset naturellement selon le professeur
Graham sur le  comité diffusé dire
conscience Bank a low près d'un paysan et
Apache voir Molina sur Pierce extrema me
pal police hola pues e  l cas de puente
Antonio et un chercheur de commissaire sur le
balcon Tom SEO donc City Japan seul
effet individuel supprimé
faisons également défiler emoji un petit
pignon conditionnel de l'univers Dena un
perceptible Je sais que la ruée vers le croissant maintenant une
autre réunion d'affaires a été ajournée
et ce qui s'est passé avec le
comité consultatif indépendant a annoncé  par le
ministre les noms des deux Québécois
Alan Lottie et Mariana étaient
introuvables dans le rapport publié en
décembre dernier GM Comité sénatorial CalSTRS man
kakoton a vanity fuji sahaba époque où
je vais satin reserve abajo function
man's candy paruparu cigale a bodybag
antique in  une lettre adressée au
ministre la professeure remet en
cause l'indépendance du
comité
elle écrit des hauts fonctionnaires à l'
Agence du revenu du Canada et le président
du comité a déterminé l'ordre du jour les
sujets discutés et les questions soulevées
exquise salle bancale le plafonnement
surtout pas une étiologie
sifflet de dépôt de Nez est montré considérer
esturgeon atomique par nécessité 1 Samuel
Curtis virgule chilidog repentir cubique
eadamson perte de demi-vérité lavage KPMG
de hong kong kappa tech15 le stockage peut
clignoter
pendant des années les experts fiscaux de kpmg ont vendu leur
stratagème à des clients fortunés les aidant à
cacher leur fortune à l'
Agence du revenu du Canada
combien  des multimillionnaires ont acheté
le stratagème et qui sont-ils?
silver sawol sukira
Toshiba see the 1283 said the vanity
blue oceans we know Ben Affleck
[Musique]
donc ta péninsule légale jusqu'à l'île de
Man
nous avons trouvé des indices dans le registre des sociétés
nous permettant d'identifier plusieurs
canadiens impliqués nous recherchons des sociétés
avec des statuts  qui étaient
identiques à ceux de la société de la
famille Cooper certains articles insolites ont
attiré notre attention comme  e celui-ci
interdisant aux administrateurs de se rencontrer au
Canada nous avons trouvé plus de 20 entreprises de
cette façon l'une d'elles a vu Jackie Company
Limited créée en 2000 un canadien siège
au conseil d'administration Frederick
William a été administrateur chez gold video
tall limited donc Jackie est aussi le nom
d'une société de portefeuille canadienne qui
appartient à la famille Xiang Yan fondateurs
du géant de la communication vidéo parler
pourquoi les ombres par le stratagème KPMG
ne nous kpop que pour nous embêter à Sioux City et
dénote dans l'unité technique un post sur Mindanao
bhakti-rasa pour pourquoi sensible Scott  nous
trouvons d'autres indices révélateurs sir Jackie a
été enregistré à l'île de Man
Le 3 février 2000 le même jour à la
Barbade et dans d'autres paradis fiscaux
donc Jackie holding et donc des
investissements Jackie ont été créés à d'autres
sociétés liées aux Shang Yuans
pour c'est plus tard à Montréal une presse
la conférence a envoyé une onde de choc dans
le paysage politique québécois c'est un grand jour
pour le Canada c'est un grand jour pour le Québec
et c'est très excitant  un pour nos
entreprises la famille Xiang a annoncé une
fusion de la vidéo d'or Tom avec Rogers
Communications détenue par le
milliardaire ontarien Ted Rogers une transaction
évaluée à 5,6 milliards de dollars depuis Suzy
Olivet Rogers
vous savez qu'en tant qu'action policière je la
ramène à un vous tout aussi clair  et un grand
avantage pour le propre portefeuille de la Chine
puisque la transaction impliquait l'échange
d'actions. Shan Young pourrait différer le paiement
de l'impôt sur les plus-values ​​en repoussant une
facture fiscale qui aurait pu atteindre plus de
700 millions de dollars. West a rejeté l'
homme olivier faisant partie de la planification fiscale de Chanel.
Oprah dit que l'équipe de Kevin Suki est une place
dans les sutures pitocin FA lepetit skv écoute
caca charité poursuivre Street organique
italien mais les chaînes ont fait face à un
défi inattendu du gouvernement du Québec
McAfee Anton de première fois
que Rogers aller a Qatari Lillet are
extraordinaire entrepreneur Shannon
Shetty
a  la théorie se concentre sur les vitamines ET dans
la peau de porc et le druide madanpal a abandonné
comme dépôts a  Cecil Skell nain
irrégulier G Saddam a fait un don pour
Medicaid le pharmacien aux amandes douces les
jours de garde a accordé l'affaire le défaut d'un
actionnaire de vidéo Tom a utilisé son droit de
veto pour bloquer la transaction l'affaire a
ensuite demandé à Piaf Calpol un propriétaire de chien de
téléphérique de  faire une contre-
offre rejetée pour la première fois par les canaux bétail colpal
aimait la police de Rogers
jeter accidentellement un filet pas costume et un son mais l'
offre de voitures pour enfants était en espèces Zhang
Yuans aurait dû payer immédiatement des
impôts sur les gains en capital hommes cabine
Hoffa dans un pochoir is  Ce
n'est pas une population nécessiteuse que Tony Hawk peut avoir pour objectif
de déclin Becker dit que l'académicien semble
handicapé face à l'opposition de la
distribution, les chaînes se sont retirées le 27 avril
puis dans leur entreprise de l'île de Man
sans l'avoir utilisée, ma chaîne de griffe de courrier électronique
confirme qu'aucun actif ou  les fonds
ont été transférés à la société Iowa man
sept jours plus tard, la fondation Lucy Ananda
chanyeol a été enregistrée auprès de
l'Agence du revenu du Canada  La fondation ncy a
reçu une grande partie des revenus
générés par la vente de la ville vidéo à
la stratégie d'attaque chimique qui n'a pas
nui à l'image des chaînes car ils sont devenus
des philanthropes de premier plan parmi les
autres sociétés de l'île de Man. Nous trouvons des
investissements gask créés en 2001, selon nos recherches.
est-il lié au neveu de Ted Rogers,
David Robinson, il a été pendant de nombreuses
années vice-président chez Rogers
Communications, il est maintenant vice-
président principal à la Banque Rogers. Robinson a
refusé de répondre à nos courriels et
messages téléphoniques. neige a été créée en 2004
pour les Québécois sont liés  à elle Oh Malik
voir un entrepreneur immobilier qui
passe les hivers en Floride d'après
son notaire il s'est installé avec une
agence du revenu du Canada et de l'avenue Québec l'
autre est andre a dessiné Homme
ancien entrepreneur de comptoir de cuisine dans la
lettre Vaughn nous a dit qu'il était simplement un
candidat  pour la causeuse, je n'ai jamais transféré
d'actifs, mais je n'étais qu'une figure de proue pour
aider, dit-il, la société baryum est
liée à  entreprise de confiserie Winnipeg
la famille d'oiseaux propriétaire de l'usine nutty club
établie il y a plus de cent
ans son président Jim Burt admet que
KPMG l'a approché il dit qu'il
n'a pas acheté le projet un de ses fils se
présente comme directeur de la société offshore
certains documents suggèrent que s KH est
lié au milliardaire ontarien Vig
n'est pas récipiendaire de l'Ordre du
Canada impliqué dans l'immobilier commercial
et l'industrie du plastique au nord de
Toronto et investit en attendant la
pensée en 2012 sk h a été transféré à
st.  Kitts et Nevis un paradis fiscal des Caraïbes
la nouvelle adresse de sjh
s'avère être la même qu'un complexe de luxe appartenant
à la victime, il a également refusé de répondre à nos
questions un citadin est venu comme un
désordre national dans un petit
laboratoire de célécoxib et a préféré  tout le
public entier la faute des phénomènes provient d'
une fuite l'un des administrateurs de Cal far 43
est le Michigan sait que l'actuel PDG de
resolute Quebec slaw exhorte
l'entreprise de l'industrie forestière mon courriel il écrit que
son rôle au sein de cette société était une
affaire privée
qui a précédé son  association avec
résolu, il dit qu'il ne peut divulguer aucune
information confidentielle concernant les
autres et que lui et sa famille n'ont
reçu aucun avantage personnel si le
pétrole du Michigan n'est que le front que le riche
Canadien se cache derrière Cal Fire 43 le
mystère reste
l'automne dernier des experts fiscaux du monde entier  le
monde a goûté à la vie nocturne légendaire de Madrid
la conférence annuelle de l'
Association fiscale internationale
dont KPMG est l'un des principaux  les sponsors ont
organisé des événements somptueux à certains des
points de repère du fil le somptueux
musée du Prado a été loué pour une soirée culturelle
parmi les participants à cet événement Le
juge Denny Ben C de la Cour
d'appel fédérale sa cour entend les appels de
la Cour de l'impôt
un porte-parole a d'abord refusé le juge
a déjà assisté à des événements d'hospitalité,
y compris celui du Prado parce que
sa femme ne se sentait pas bien, mais les
voici après avoir révélé que nous avions tourné
cette vidéo, son porte-parole a admis qu'il avait
assisté aux événements et a déclaré que la
confusion initiale était due à une
mauvaise communication deux jours plus tard, il y
avait  une soirée privée sur invitation uniquement
sur l'une des terrasses les plus exclusives de
la capitale espagnole le toit l'événement a
été entièrement payé par la branche canadienne
du cabinet d'avocats Denton's Marwa risqué a
assisté à la conférence mais pas le
cocktail privé préfixe mafia et cette
huître a le  consultation k12 et
Bischoff disent que cela fonctionne sur une
cuillère d'erreur le kdeeny cloggin est à nouveau allumé
Scot  t D devient ce qu'il vient de dire à la
cuisine et c'est une Nancy qui l'a tiré vers
le gars du marketing Thomas sur nous de
l'ancienne Fraser Milner de Chandni Denton était le
cabinet qui a fourni des conseils juridiques en 1999
à KPMG validant le programme de l'île de Man
parmi les participants à
la fête de Denton  était un autre
juge canadien Randall bull cock de la Cour de l'impôt,
il est le juge de gestion dans l'affaire
impliquant le stratagème de KPMG sur l'île de Man dans
la famille Cooper.
soin qui concerne le public à son
adversité
Nancy de quoi yo yo yo yo tourner correos
cartel de danseur SEO Papa Bobby maman
Missy Paula soutien neffeteria vous savez
beurre de spaghetti si le
ratio de processus de plasma époxy risque que
nos neveux neveu principal d'annapolis et
c'est comme ça que c'est écrit  dans le
code de déontologie des conseils judiciaires canadiens, le
professeur Leo croit que le
juge en chef de la Cour de l'impôt de Ca  nada
devrait appeler ses juges pour ordonner le
directeur de la défense Joseph Rossiter est-ce que j'ai rencontré injecter
des problèmes graves puis un pop qui a craché à
la queue Teleca Driscoll Lamar
délicieux je vois que j'ai épluché mais
le juge en chef n'est pas d'accord vous
connaissez un e-mail il dit que juge  Volkov
ne s'est pas mis en situation de
conflit d'intérêts en
assistant brièvement à une réception ouverte à
tous les participants de la conférence lors d'
une autre conférence sur la fiscalité à Calgary
quelques mois plus tard, loin de
condamner la pratique que le juge en
chef l'a encouragée en se vantant de vouloir
lui-même continue d'assister à des
événements d'accueil
ma Camaro chronique la si table
étiquetée une voiture avec une posture de pénalité
énorme scalaire japonais contient les mascottes
château de conneries indécis aux États-
Unis les autorités ont traduit KPMG en
justice pour avoir vendu des abris fiscaux abusifs
pendant la même période que le
Régime de l'île de Man au Canada, nous ne pouvons tout simplement
pas tolérer un abus flagrant de la loi
et de l'ordre professionnel  des conseils par des
professionnels de la fiscalité, en particulier ceux
associés à des entreprises dites de premier ordre
telles que KPMG. Michael Hammersley, avocat fiscaliste, a
travaillé pour KPMG aux États-Unis.
en 2003, il est devenu un lanceur d'alerte
contre son ancien employeur.
J'ai finalement refusé d'approuver ce que
je croyais être une conduite illégale des
partenaires fiscaux de KPMG impliqués dans l'audit
peu de temps après que les professionnels ont perdu
leur
boussole de responsabilités morales et professionnelles et ils ont
pensé et je pense que le  les conséquences
ont été beaucoup plus graves qu'ils ne l'avaient
prévu aux états-unis.  huit cadres supérieurs de
KPMG ont été inculpés trois d'
entre eux sont allés en prison un cabinet d'experts-comptables a été
condamné à une amende de 456 millions de dollars league rockin
a hotel no decapitation hacia el
emilio de dólar de PhD la cuillère soufie un pays
AFET a co trailer
imagine a co crayon Ellis L sang Co
possible  Kiva par le leila decision la
tradición de Liberty yo pal ha
Damodar don't defend a prisoner session
Sissoko body the Nisswa Yosh
s'échappant ainsi au Canada KPMG et leurs
comptables ne font jamais face à la justice cabinet
qui se voit toujours attribuer des millions de dollars en
contrats chaque année par le gouvernement fédéral
Alice hey Encantada Ricardo ho chi
gentils gars comme Amazon les
divas disco sur Scott un ducat J'annulerai le
contrat
KPMG soutient que son plan a été très
soigneusement développé et examiné et
qu'il était conforme aux lois certains disent que
l'entreprise devrait faire l'objet d'une
enquête policière  stratagème et pour ses
relations avec l'Agence du revenu du Canada
dernier épisode des solutions adéquates, vous savez,
Kate et moi avons découvert da na  GFC pour le
baiser composé entre le compte d'actifs et l'
utilisation de KPMG lassie, vous verrez que la
ghréline fait partie de notre pas aussi
privilégié, donc réussi, l'identité
des véritables propriétaires de certaines des sociétés de l'île de
Man reste toujours un mystère pour la
plupart de l'offshore  les structures ont maintenant
été liquidées en raison de l'amnistie
négociée par KPMG certains de ces
multimillionnaires n'auront pas à faire face à la
justice pour l'instant ils restent intouchables
[Musique]